[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Uns ist heute nach einer Eistorte.
Und ich hatte kurz überlegt,
ob ich nicht eine Nougat-Eistorte machen soll,
was ja schon echt schon ziemlich gigantisch gewesen wäre.
Aber dann
habe ich was in meinem Kühlschrank entdeckt
und bin so: "Woah!"
Ich mache
eine Kinder-Bueno-Eistorte
ganz ohne Backen.
Und die Torte, die wird der Hammer!
Supereinfach in der Herstellung.
Dekoration überlege ich mir noch.
Geschmack wird der Hammer!
Ich verwende dafür
– den zuerst mache ich ja die Creme –
250 Gramm Mascarpone,
acht Kinder Bueno,
250 Gramm Sahne,
etwas San-apart zum Steifschlagen
und Butterkekse.
Ich nehme jetzt zuerst die Kinder Bueno.
Also eigentlich solltet ihr neun nehmen.
Denn einen könnt ihr vernaschen.
Aber ich bin nicht so die Naschkatze
und probiere nicht so viel und so.
Ich freue mich einfach später auf das Stück Torte.
Das kommt jetzt hier in eine Schüssel.
Okay, was ich jetzt echt sagen muss,
es ist echt ein bisschen
Verpackungsalarm.
Also da finde ich es ein bisschen schade,
dass die alle einzeln verpackt sind.
Vor allem glaube ich, liebt ja jeder Bueno.
Das heißt, man könnte sie ja im Prinzip
auch in eine Big-Verpackung machen,
Jumbo-Verpackung.
Und ich will bitte betonen,
ich mache keine Werbung für die Firma Kinder,
ich mache keine Werbung für die Firma Ferrero.
Ich benutze einfach nur das Produkt
und ich bekomme nichts dafür.
Ich habe die Kinder Bueno selbst bezahlt.
Und vielleicht werde ich es irgendwann kopieren
und einfach ein Kinder Bueno selber machen.
Wenn ja, schreibt gerne in die Kommentare.
Oh, so ein XXL-Kinder-Bueno!
Josh?
>> JOSH: Mein Blick sagt schon alles.
>> SALLY: Ja, dein Blick sagt schon alles!
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
wenn wir ein XXL-Kinder-Bueno machen sollen.
Lecker!
Und ich mache noch eine Kinder-Bueno-Torte.
Denn das wurde schon lange, lange, lange gewünscht.
So.
Verpackung muss weg.
Also das finde ich echt schade,
dass alles so in Plastik und viel Verpackung verpackt ist.
Aber
ist halt so.
Lebensmittel.
Sodele.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach irgendwas zum Zerstampfen
so ganz brutal.
Ihr könnt auch einen Mixer nehmen.
Alle Jahre wieder
kommt das Sallykind
in die Küche nieder,
wo ihre Kinder sind.
Und sie warten alle
auf den Kuchen schon,
den sie hat gebacken
für ihren
nicht existierenden Sohn.
Komm, sag schon. Was reimt sie auf schon?
Ich texte noch mal um, ja?
Ich überlege mir was Neues.
Manchmal frage ich mich so:
Was hat sie genommen?
Was hat sie genommen heute Morgen?
Es ist, muss ich sagen, noch sehr früh.
Es ist der erste Dreh heute.
Und deswegen kann ich auch kein Kinder Bueno naschen,
weil ich hatte noch nicht mal ein Frühstück.
Ja, ich bin noch so im
Schlafmodus.
Aber dann schon...
Na ja, egal.
Machen wir weiter.
Also da kommt jetzt die Mascarpone dazu.
Statt Mascarpone könnt ihr auch Quark nehmen
oder Frischkäse.
Mascarpone ist einfach supercremig
und passt geschmacklich super dazu,
so mild und cremig.
Quark ist eher so ein bisschen säuerlicher,
passt auch, wenn man so die Kombination aus Schokolade
und diesem Säuerlichen mag.
Und Frischkäse hat so ein leicht salzigen Geschmack,
passt aber auch,
muss man aber mögen.
Ich habe mich jetzt für Mascarpone entschieden.
Das wird jetzt kurz verrührt.
Dann gebt ihr hier jetzt die Sahne dazu
ganz langsam.
[Musik]
Ta-daa!
Immer auskratzen.
Guckt mal, was da noch drin hängt!
Hm.
Ich glaube, deswegen
backt Samira lieber alleine als mit mir,
weil Mama immer alles auskratzt.
Dann hat sie nichts zum Abschlecken.
So.
Dann machen wir kurz eine Geschmacksprobe.
Denn ich weiß nicht, ob die Süßkraft schon reicht.
Josh, mach Ah.
Magst du probieren?
Und du sagst dann, ob das genug Bueno ist.
Okay?
Also deine Verantwortung.
Oder noch ein bisschen?
Ich habe nämlich fast im Gefühl,
ein bisschen könnte noch.
Vor allem, wenn man die Torte einfriert, dann verliert sie
so ein bisschen an Geschmack und Süßungskraft.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir stocken auf.
Mit zwei?
>> JOSH: Das ist ein bisschen sehr sahnig.
Schmeckt wenig nach Bueno.
>> SALLY: Dann nehmen wir noch vier.
Gut.
Das wollte ich wissen.
Da-da-da-daa!
Ich habe ja genug eingekauft.
[Musik]
Die kann ich ja sogar ein bisschen stückig lassen.
Hu!
Für den Crunch.
Oh.
Ich wollte nichts zerstören hier.
Da-da-da-da-daa-daa!
Okay, jetzt kommt das nächste Weihnachtslied.
Was stimmt mit mir nicht?!
Wir machen doch gerade eine Sommer-Eistorte
und in meinem Kopf ist so Weihnachten.
Jingle bells,
jingle all the way!
O what fun it is to ride
in a one-horse open sleigh!
[Musik]
Und dann kann ich es verrühren
und mit San-apart steif schlagen.
[Musik]
Okay.
Josh, dein Probierlöffel.
Bereit?
Den darfst du loben.
Löffel und Probierlöffel.
>> JOSH: Oh ja!
>> SALLY: Ja?
Reicht?
>> JOSH: Hm.
Vor allem der Crunch!
>> SALLY: Oh yes!
>> JOSH: Der macht es noch mal ein ganzes Stück besser.
Gute Idee!
>> SALLY: Ja!
Okay.
Ich räume kurz auf.
Und dann schichten wir schon die Torte.
Also es geht echt megaschnell, wie ihr sehen könnt.
So.
Jetzt habe ich hier ein Dauerbackfolie
– ihr könnt auch Backpapier nehmen –
und lege jetzt sozusagen die Kekse nebeneinander,
drei Stück.
Da gibt es auch Schokokekse.
Aber die waren gerade nicht lieferbar.
So schade!
Also nicht erhältlich.
Ich habe sie gekauft und nicht liefern lassen.
Die waren gerade nicht erhältlich.
Denn ich denke, Schokokekse wären noch mal so
on top.
Das würde perfekter passen.
Und die lege ich jetzt hier noch untereinander.
Das erinnert mich jetzt tatsächlich ans Lebkuchenhausbauen.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier drei mal sieben.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, ob es passt.
Jetzt kommt nämlich die Creme in die Mitte.
Uppsala!
Ups!
Okay, Josh, du hast recht.
Ich habe so viele Ups-Situationen.
Ich merke es selber schon nicht mehr.
Oh, wow!
Ich hatte gerade den Einfall meines Lebens!
Ich lege noch in die Mitte längs ein Bueno rein.
Oh!
O mein Gott!
Und dann beim Aufschneiden hast du diesen
– oh! –
diesen Querschnitt!
Seht ihr?
So entstehen meine Rezepte.
So!
In der Situation.
Und jetzt überlegt mal.
Beim Dreh geht das ja oft so schon so spontan.
Aber jetzt überlegt mal, wenn ich so ein Backbuch mache,
da bin ich die ganze Zeit so.
Weißt du, weil,
wenn ich jetzt am Anfang eine Zutat nicht zeige,
dann meckert ihr und sagt:
"Wieso hast du die am Anfang nicht gezeigt?"
Also muss ich mir am Anfang schon überlegen,
was ich mache.
Aber dann kommt mir währenddessen noch eine coole Idee.
Und im Buch da bin ich dann so:
"Woah! Und dies noch und das noch."
Ich bin zehnmal am Rezeptumschreiben.
Und jetzt hier so
– wow!
Also bitte verzeiht mir,
dass ich die Buenos nicht gezeigt habe.
Aber
es kommt gleich ein Bueno in die Mitte.
Wow!
So eine ungesunde Torte
habe ich schon lang nicht mehr gemacht.
Aber, hey, die wird genial!
So leicht verteilen.
Okay, vielleicht war das schon zu viel Inhalt.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Dann lege ich es einfach quer und mache eine Reihe dran.
Also ist halt so.
Da-daa-da-da!
>> JOSH: Du könntest zwei hoch mit reinmachen,
dann die Wände links und rechts hochklappen
und oben noch so einen Dachfirst aus Kinder Bueno machen.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Okay, ich hätte einfach auch,
wie Julia vorhin schon sagte,
eine Pyramide aus Kinder Bueno machen können zum Essen
und einfach einfrieren.
Okay, ich versuche das jetzt hier in der Mitte
zu glätten.
Wir gucken einfach, was passiert jetzt gleich, okay?
Und dann entscheiden wir, wie die Form wird.
Es kann sein, dass es schön wird.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass ich eine Reihe anbaue.
Das entsteht jetzt.
Und, da ich so nett bin,
lasse ich Josh was zum
Naschen übrig.
Oh, Josh, neulich schrieb eine so:
"Der Josh ist ja auch ein ganz Süßer und so sympathisch."
Das haben schon mehrere geschrieben.
Hach!
Wow!
Okay, wenn das jetzt, ganz ehrlich,
hierein passt
längenmäßig, dann
ist
– wow!
Es musste anscheinend so sein.
Es musste diese Füllung sein.
Denn diese Länge passt perfekt.
Gut.
Jetzt muss es nur noch gut klappen.
Also
bitte, bitte, bitte!
Hier jetzt nach oben klappen.
Oh, der Keks ist gebrochen!
Nicht schlimm.
Da muss ich auch sagen,
dass die Folie wahrscheinlich besser ist als Backpapier,
weil die einfach fester ist.
Und jetzt müsst ihr praktisch so ein bisschen
die Creme
– okay, Josh, du hast noch nichts zum Schlecken.
Denn es war leider perfektes Augenmaß.
Es tut mir leid.
Dafür kriegst du später zwei Stücke Torte.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Ich habe dir verziehen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Weil, guck, hier fehlt es.
Guck, jetzt ist es perfekt.
[Musik]
Guck mal. Hier vorne einfach
die Creme nach oben streichen.
Okay.
Und jetzt
zuklappen.
So ein bisschen festziehen,
nur so ein bisschen mit Spannung.
So.
Und das nehme ich jetzt.
Ein bisschen schwierig.
Okay, das nächste Mal macht ihr es
– also ihr macht es so, ihr legt euch gleich was drunter
und packt es dann in den Gefrierschrank.
Denn ich muss jetzt leider hier ein bisschen ausbessern.
Aber, da ich die Torte einfrieren werde,
hoffe ich, geht sie jetzt nicht so allzu sehr kaputt.
Ojemine!
Okay, ich friere sie jetzt mal ein
und dann gucke ich, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich muss das noch so runter machen.
Na ja, ich friere sie mal ein.
Also ich habe jetzt die Torte im Gefrierschrank.
Aber die gefällt mir jetzt doch nicht so gut.
Ihr könnt sie dreieckig machen.
Wir machen sie auch später fertig auf jeden Fall.
Aber wir dachten uns gerade so:
"Nein. Nein, wir machen eine runde Torte."
Also habe ich die gleiche Creme noch mal hergestellt
und wollte gerade schon anfangen,
eine runde Torte zu machen,
bis mir einfällt, zack,
ich brauche einen No-Bake-Boden.
Also werde ich jetzt noch ein bisschen Butter holen,
schmelzen,
mit den Keksen verrühren
und einen No-Bake-Boden machen.
Für den Crunch-Boden nehme ich, wie gesagt, Butterkekse,
etwas Butter
und Kakaopulver
und viel Bueno!
Heute morgen dachte ich noch so:
"Hey, Kinder-Bueno-Torte, Eistorte, die geht schnell."
Und dann komme ich und
ändere halt fünf Millionen Mal die Zutaten.
Okay.
Die Butter wird kurz geschmolzen.
Die Kekse werden zerkleinert.
Das machen wir jetzt alles kurz hier im Schnelldurchgang.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Hier lege ich jetzt einfach
diesen Schmetterlingseinsatz rein.
So.
Denn damit kann ich gleich rühren.
Ich muss nur die Mitte treffen.
Habe ich sie schon?
Nein.
Da haben jetzt echt alle Kekse reingepasst!
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn!
So.
Wuhu!
Kakao rein.
Und die flüssige Butter rein.
[Musik]
Die Creme habe ich übrigens
in der Zwischenzeit in den Kühlschrank gestellt,
damit sie schön kalt bleibt.
Ein Tipp von mir:
Wenn ihr Dinge kühlen wollt,
einfach in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Okay, das ist eine leichte Überforderung des Geräts.
Ich muss echt sagen, das ist sehr, sehr, sehr viel Masse.
Aber es hat geklappt.
Aber macht es bitte nicht nach mit so viel Inhalt.
Das ist jetzt schon
sehr viel.
Yummy!
Und jetzt kommt das hier direkt in den Tortenring.
Eins, zwei, drei,
puh!
So, lieber Josh, was kommt jetzt zum Einsatz?
Was?
>> JOSH: Palette?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> JOSH: Vielleicht ein geistreicher Move.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Die Burgerpresse ist nämlich
der ideale Keksbodenzerdrücker.
Oder ein Glas.
Aber mit dem geht es einfach
viel schneller.
Denn er hat eine große Fläche,
man hat es gut in der Hand so
und vor allem, finde ich,
ist es dann einfach noch mal ein Grund zu sagen:
"Hey, eine Burgerpresse lohnt sich."
Denn, ganz ehrlich, wie oft macht man im Jahr Burger?
Jetzt nicht so oft vielleicht.
Okay, Josh vielleicht. Okay.
Aber jetzt da kann man dann sagen:
"Hey, ich benutze es für süße und herzhafte Gerichte."
Von daher
finde ich schon,
das passt.
Guckt einmal, wie schön glatt das ist.
Und, da jetzt bei mir die Butter nicht mehr warm ist,
muss ich jetzt auch den Boden nicht kühlstellen.
Das heißt, hier kommt direkt die Creme drauf.
Jetzt kommt die Creme hier rein.
Und guckt mal. Die ist jetzt auch schön fest.
Und ich werde jetzt hier
noch Bueno-Stücke reingeben.
Oder wäre das zu pervers, Josh?
>> JOSH: Mhm.
Das ist absolut legitim!
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also noch mal zwei.
Die Torte heißt dann irgendwie so Bueno-Torte de luxe.
Und die werde ich so reingeben,
weil so kennt man Bueno.
Und wenn man dann das richtig anschneidet,
hat man echt so
so ein halbes Stück nur so.
Das ist schon gut.
Ich hätte halt schon gern das bei jedem Tortenstück.
Deswegen so eins würde ich schon noch.
Oder ist es dann zu arg?
>> JOSH: Ich finde das okay so, wie es jetzt da so ist.
>> SALLY: So ist es okay.
Das passt.
Okay.
Und jetzt die restliche Creme einfach darüber verteilen
und gerne glatt streichen.
Ich sehe schon vor meinem geistigen Auge,
wie ich die Torte später weitermachen werde.
Ich bin jetzt aber, ehrlich gesagt,
da ein bisschen hin- und hergerissen,
ob ich jetzt die Torte geeist mache
oder ob ich sie doch nur aus dem Kühlschrank
kühlschrankkalt serviere.
Ich glaube, ich mache sie nicht komplett Eis,
also nicht eine Eis-, sondern nur eine geeiste Torte.
Das heißt, wenn ihr sie komplett einfriert,
dann ist sie halt wirklich so Eis, eiskalt,
aber, wenn ihr sie jetzt nur für eine Stunde etwa
ins Gefrierfach stellt, dann ist es einfach eine geeiste Torte,
so kälter als Kühlschrank,
schön erfrischend
und eben trotzdem noch cremig genug,
weil eben nicht ganz durchgefroren.
Okay. So machen wir das jetzt.
Eine Stunde in den Gefrierschrank.
Wenn ihr sagt, "Das will ich nicht",
dann stellt sie einfach für zwei Stunden in den Kühlschrank.
Zack, zack!
Ab in die Kühlung!
[Musik]
Also die Torte ist jetzt gefroren.
Und jetzt geht es schon an die Deko.
Und zwar nehme ich
Zartbitterkuvertüre und Vollmilchkuvertüre.
>> SAMIRA: Eins.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Warte mal.
So viel brauchen wir nicht.
Eins reicht.
Und die schmelzen wir auch direkt
in so einem Gefrierbeutel.
>> SAMIRA: Dann machst du es da rein
und dann schmilzt es im Beutel.
Und dann kann man da vorne ein Loch reinmachen
und dann spritzt man es auf die Torte.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Mein Baby,
mein Baby ist schon so groß.
Warte. Warte.
Erst muss das Wasser warm werden.
Also ich lasse das Wasser kurz kochen
und schalte es dann wieder aus,
damit es nicht
>> SAMIRA: Mama, guck.
>> SALLY: zu heiß wird.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist doch schon warm.
>> SALLY: Ja,
gleich.
Und dann machen wir es auch so,
wir lassen es praktisch schmelzen,
nicht komplett, so ein bisschen.
Praktisch der innere Kern bleibt noch fest.
Ich nehme es raus
und durch das Massieren wird dann sozusagen
die Schokolade temperiert und ist nicht zu heiß.
Oh, jetzt regnet es.
Jetzt machen wir so eine schöne Eistorte
und jetzt regnet es einfach.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Na ja.
Tja.
Komm, das reicht schon.
Da hast du recht.
Jetzt hängen wir es hierein.
Zack!
>> SAMIRA: So.
Bei der einen Schokolade
– also die eine Schokolade ist jetzt schon geschmolzen.
Und jetzt massiere ich sie,
dass der innere Kern, der noch
noch nicht geschmolzen ist,
schmilzt.
>> SALLY: Jetzt lösen wir hier die Torte raus.
Die ist wirklich so halb geeist, Samira.
Und es ist eine...
Weiß du, was das für eine Torte gibt?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, eine Bueno-Torte.
Weil da Bueno steht.
>> SALLY: Oh, stimmt.
Das war so dieser Moment,
ich überrasche das Kind und dann, zack,
>> SAMIRA: Und es riecht nach Bueno.
>> SALLY: das Kind war schlauer als ich.
Jetzt.
Lecker.
Lecker, lecker, lecker!
Und jetzt machen wir Folgendes.
Ich streiche hier erst mal noch mal glatt
und hier. Da habe ich aus Versehen den Ring angestoßen.
Okay.
Du weiß, was wir jetzt tun?
>> SAMIRA: Ja,
diese Glasur drübermachen.
>> SALLY: Gib mal her. Ich zeige dir wie.
Am besten hier die Schokolade so ein bisschen runter,
hier die Spitze weg,
weil diese Spitze, die nervt immer so ein bisschen,
und dann erst
klein wegschneiden.
Und gleich die Schnipsel weg,
damit die nicht in der Torte landen.
Jetzt machen wir so ein bisschen die Bueno-Optik, okay?
>> SAMIRA: Also die Streifen.
>> SALLY: Das heißt die Streifen.
Und ich würde auch sagen,
dass wir erst mal nur in eine Richtung.
Und dann gucken wir, wie es uns gefällt.
>> SAMIRA: Dann müsste ich zuerst anfangen,
weil die dunkleren kommen dann drauf.
>> SALLY: Mh.
Okay.
Warte.
Oh! Ah, da! Warte.
Ich zweige dir wie.
Komm mal ganz kurz.
Weil nicht in der
– also nicht in der Mitte anfangen.
Sonst hast du so in der Mitte so einen Klotz.
Das heißt, wir fangen immer am Rand an.
Das ist echt cool, dass du dabei bist!
Weil dann sehe ich,
was man vielleicht so noch besser,
noch besser machen kann als du.
Weil du bist ja schon ein Pro,
so ein richtiger Pro.
Guck. Du fängst praktisch hier an
und lässt es dann so rüberlaufen
und hast wirklich immer so schöne dünne.
>> SAMIRA: Ah!
>> SALLY: Und dann hat man nicht in der Mitte
– weil, wenn ich jetzt so mache,
siehst du, dann hat man in der Mitte so einen Blödsinn.
Okay.
>> SAMIRA: Du bedeckst ja die ganze Torte mit Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, wir machen es doch so,
wirklich so kreuz und quer.
Genau, dann machst du die dunkle Variante.
>> SAMIRA: Variante.
>> SALLY: Und immer so zack,
>> SAMIRA: Eins, zwei, drei.
>> SALLY: so ein dünner Strich.
Und los!
Genau.
Und am besten bleibst du auf der Folie.
Erspart später viel Arbeit.
Ja.
Super!
Perfekt!
O mein Gott! Das sieht echt aus wie Bueno!
Oder?
>> SAMIRA: Ja. Aber, wenn wir noch Bueno drauf machen...
>> SALLY: Okay, das reicht.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, ob wir
die nicht einfach
– warte mal, ich halbiere mal.
So an den Rand, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Oh ja, das wäre cool!
>> SALLY: Aber das machen wir jetzt so,
wir setzen erst mal die Torte auf die Platte.
Das heißt, warte kurz, ich hole
eine Winkelpalette.
Guck mal. Wir machen jetzt Teamwork. Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und zwar
ich hebe die Torte hoch,
du nimmst
– das ist jetzt richtig Teamwork!
Ihr könnt natürlich auch einfach
das Papier drunter wegziehen und rüberheben.
Aber wir machen jetzt Teamwork.
Also ich hebe die Torte hoch
du ziehst das Papier weg und die Platte dahin. Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Denn wir sind ein Team.
Okay, Papier weg.
Vorsicht, nicht auf den Boden.
Wow!
Es macht gleich einen mega Unterschied,
wenn man so eine Torte dann schön anrichtet.
Also ich finde die jetzt schon wunderschön.
Wirklich!
Die könnte man jetzt auch schon so lassen.
Ich bin echt gerade am Überlegen.
Machen wir sie an den Rand?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, wir legen immer so ein Stück oben rein,
– guck mal, Sami –
dass wir sozusagen...
Wir probieren es einfach aus.
Vielleicht einfach so ein Stück so.
Weißt du?
So.
Und dann so...
So?
Oder...
Ich weiß es nicht.
Oder halt an den Rand.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist zermatscht.
>> SALLY: Okay. Was meint ihr?
Wir machen kurz eine Abstimmung.
Was meinst du?
Obendrauf?
>> SAMIRA: Mh.
>> SALLY: Oder an den Rand?
>> SAMIRA: Ich finde sie an dem Rand besser.
>> SALLY: Was sagst du, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ich würde mit einem Messer
das untere Kissen halbieren,
dass es so genau an der Kante dann ist,
oben dass es nicht raussteht.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Und dann an den Rand.
>> SALLY: Was sagst du, Sarah?
>> SARAH: Ich wäre für obendrauf.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY & SAMIRA: Und Julia?
>> JULIA: Die Julia hat keine Meinung. Sie isst alles.
>> SALLY: Ich probiere es mal.
Ich probiere es mal mit dem Messer
mit dem Rand.
Weil ich finde es auch am Rand schon auch geil.
Also...
>> JULIA: Der ist in der Mitte kletschig.
>> SALLY: Wir haben halt nicht mehr so viele Buenos.
Wir müssen, glaube ich, noch mal kaufen.
>> SAMIRA: Aber wir haben doch noch so viele gehabt.
Wo sind die alle?
>> SALLY: Die sind in der anderen Torte.
Ja, sieht schon gut aus.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass wir jetzt praktisch immer die Randstücke brauchen.
Das hätte ich mir
– also das kann man sich echt vorher tatsächlich überlegen.
Dann schneidet immer, guckt mal, eins und das halbe.
Und den Rest, praktisch der Verschnitt,
>> SAMIRA: Den mag ich essen.
>> SALLY: den Verschnitt nehmt ihr dann für die Creme.
So kann man es machen.
Weil ich hätte jetzt schon gern
hier oben immer die geschlossene Seite.
Das heißt, – warte mal – dann hat man immer hier
so die Mitte.
Oder
– wir gucken, wie es aussieht –
nehmen wir vielleicht noch die Mitte so dazwischen.
>> SAMIRA: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe nur Nein gesagt,
dass ich es essen kann,
eigentlich.
>> SALLY: Es sieht schon
– was meinst du?
Ist schon...
Das sieht schon gut aus.
Okay. Kann kurz jemand Bueno kaufen?
>> SARAH: Du hast gar nichts für mich?
>> SALLY: So. Jetzt keine mehr aufessen, ja?
Weil ich muss die jetzt auch abwiegen,
damit ich es ins Rezept schreiben kann,
damit
das dann gleich passt von der Menge.
Weil ich muss jetzt schon dazusagen,
also das hätte ich mir jetzt wirklich vorher überlegen können.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich schreibe euch dann einfach
in das Rezept, in die App,
wie viele ihr braucht.
Denn ihr braucht keine sieben Packungen.
Und dann nehmt ihr einfach am Anfang die Buenos,
schneidet wirklich für die Deko diese zurecht
und diesen Verschnitt, den nehmt ihr für die Creme, okay?
Dann passt das.
>> SARAH: Wie viele Packungen?
>> SALLY: Mh.
Hol mal vier Packungen.
[Musik]
Wir haben jetzt nur noch die Tortenplatte gewechselt.
Denn die war einfach zu klein mit dem Rand.
Also eigentlich hätte der Durchmesser gepasst,
aber...
>> SAMIRA: Ela, Ela, Ela! Pass auf bei der Torte!
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?!
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe es ihr gegeben.
>> SALLY: Hast du da was weggenascht?
Und jetzt passt es.
Und jetzt kleben wir einfach die Buenos hier an den Rand.
Und dann ist sie fertig
und kann fotografiert werden.
Und danach dürft ihr zwei probieren.
Okay?
Ihr seid dann die Kuchentester,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Möchtet ihr?
>> SAMIRA & ELA: Hm.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Da hat man einfach einen anderen Geschmack.
>> ELA: Samira,
du kleine Naschliese!
Du kleine Naschkatze!
>> SALLY: Hier, Samira.
>> ELA: Mama, du hast noch ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Gibst du mir noch mal zwei?
>> ELA: Ja.
Soll ich die aufmachen?
Darf ich bitte aufmachen, Mama?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Hier.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Perfekt, Samira!
Ich glaube, das reicht, Ela.
[Musik]
So. Wie gefällt euch die Torte?
>> ELA: Gut!
Gut. Gut.
>> SALLY: Mir auch.
Perfekt sieht sie aus.
Okay. Weißt du was? Wir tauschen doch die zwei hier aus.
Denn die sind so ein bisschen angeknabbert unten.
Aber wir naschen jetzt nichts mehr.
Wir warten jetzt auf die Torte.
Also bis gleich zum Probieren!
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Ela!
>> SALLY: Ela, hast du genascht?
Sagst du die Wahrheit?
>> ELA: Ich war es.
>> SALLY: Warst du es?
>> SALLY: Das darf man aber nicht.
Man muss immer die Wahrheit sagen.
Hast du genascht?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Aber jetzt reicht es, gell?
Komm.
[Musik]
Probieren wir mal!
Los!
Eine geeiste Torte.
Ich probiere von da hinten, wenn es okay ist.
>> SAMIRA: Ich probiere das da hier.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Und?
Ela probiert natürlich ein Bueno.
Und der Josh darf auch probieren.
>> SAMIRA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Josh,
probiere.
Wir haben ja schon die Komponenten probiert,
>> SAMIRA: Ernsthaft?
aber...
Komm, Bahti.
>> JOSH: Der No-Bake-Boden war auf jeden Fall
die richtige Entscheidung.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hier kommt noch der
No-Bake-Torten-
No-Bake-Cake-Spezialist.
>> BAHTIYAR: Ich habe jetzt hinter der Kamera geguckt
wie so ein kleiner Hund wahrscheinlich.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> BAHTIYAR: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Bahti ist der No-Bake-Cake-Spezialist.
Und guckt mal da innen drin
hat sich es versteckt,
das Kinder Bueno.
Guckt!
Mmh!
>> BAHTIYAR: Gut.
>> SALLY: Gut, gell?
>> BAHTIYAR: Ist da Banane drin?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Keine Banane.
Nur Bueno.
>> BAHTIYAR: Cool!
>> SALLY: Oh, ist das lecker!
>> BAHTIYAR: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Leckerschmecker!
Aber ich finde auch, die Konsistenz erinnert so
an Banane.
Also auf jeden Fall unbedingt nachmachen!
Die dreieckige Torte haben wir jetzt leider auch noch übrig.
Also, Josh,
leider gibt es heute noch mehr Kuchen.
>> JOSH: Schade.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, wir können mit allen teilen.
Aber ich finde die Version echt die beste.
Also probiert sie unbedingt aus!
Postet ein Foto!
Und viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
>> BAHTIYAR: Ela, darf ich noch ein Stück haben?
>> ELA: Hm.
Du kannst das haben.
>> SALLY: Echt? Darf er das Ganze haben?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ach, wie lieb!
Ach, du süße Maus!
Jetzt sagt sie so: "Ich habe ja noch den Rest."
>> BAHTIYAR: Ich kann auch an deinem Bauch knabbern.
Dann habe ich auch ein Mittagessen.
>> SALLY: Tschüssi!
[Musik]